Harper High School, South Side of Chicago, first day of school this year, first thing in the morning, everybody gathers in the gym for a beginning of the year assembly.
芝加哥南区的哈珀高中，今年开学的第一天，清晨时分，所有人聚集在体育馆参加开学典礼。
[GYM CHATTER]
[体育馆内的嘈杂声]
The School's principal, Leonetta Sanders, is at the mic.
学校校长莱奥内塔·桑德斯（Leonetta Sanders）站在麦克风前。
I need us to begin to quiet down.
我需要大家开始安静下来。
Sitting all together in a group are the freshmen, looking the way that freshmen do on the first day of school, like they barely know who they are--
一群一年级新生聚在一起坐着，看起来就像开学第一天的新生一样，仿佛连自己是谁都还不太清楚——
The Class of 2016, where you at? The Class of 2016, where you at?
2016届的学生，你们在哪儿？2016届的学生，你们在哪儿？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Down in front, sitting together, are the seniors, looking the way seniors do on the first day of school--
坐在前排的是高年级学生，看起来就像开学第一天的高年级学生一样——
And then my babies are here, my Class of 2013, (YELLING) where you at?
还有我的宝贝们，我的2013届学生，（大喊）你们在哪儿？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
The program is 1/3 pep rally, 2/3 business, introductions, and rules. Exactly the kind of first day stuff you'd expect at any school, till it's not.
这场典礼三分之一是动员会，三分之二则是正事、介绍和校规。这正是你在任何学校都会预料到的开学第一天的情景，直到它变得不再寻常。
Last year was a difficult year for most of us, for all of us in the Harper community. You know, and the freshman may not know, but we lost three students last year.
去年对我们大多数人，对哈珀社区的所有人来说，都是艰难的一年。你们知道，可能一年级新生不知道，但我们去年失去了三名学生。
This is actually underplaying the bad news. Last year, 21 kids, current and recent Harper students, were wounded by gunshots. Five recent students died. And that is all on top of the three current students that Miss Sanders mentioned. Total, 29 shot, eight of them dead.
这其实还是淡化了坏消息。去年，有21名哈珀在读及刚毕业的学生遭到枪击受伤。五名刚毕业的学生不幸身亡。这还不包括桑德斯校长提到的那三名在校生。总计29人中枪，其中8人死亡。
But we know that their spirits are with us. So right now, I just want to ask for a moment of silence and prayer as we think about and remember the students that have fallen. So at this time, I'm just going to ask that we take about 20, 30 seconds, just for a moment of silence for Marcus Nunn, Cedric Bell, and Shakaki Asphy, right now.
但我们知道他们的精神与我们同在。所以现在，我请求大家保持片刻沉默并进行祈祷，让我们怀念并追忆那些逝去的学生。此时此刻，我请求大家默哀20到30秒，为了马库斯·纳恩（Marcus Nunn）、塞德里克·贝尔（Cedric Bell）和沙卡基·阿斯菲（Shakaki Asphy），就在现在。
Watching this, it's hard not to think that if you grafted these facts onto another high school in a wealthier place, maybe a suburb, dozens of students shot, three of them killed-- in other places, that would be national news, right? We would all know the name of that school.
看着这一幕，很难不想到，如果把这些事实放在富裕地区的另一所高中，比如郊区，几十名学生被枪击，其中三人死亡——在其他地方，这会成为全国新闻，对吧？我们都会知道那所学校的名字。
It's worth noting that this is a gym filled with hundreds of teenagers who, this very same morning, have been asked over and over to be quiet. And who, like most teenagers, haven't exactly jumped to. When this moment comes, nothing moves.
值得注意的是，这是一个挤满了数百名青少年的体育馆，就在这个早晨，他们被反复要求保持安静。像大多数青少年一样，他们并没有立刻照做。当这一刻来临时，所有人都静止不动了。
Praise God.
感谢上帝。
And then, high school resumes.
随后，高中生活继续。
At this time, again, for the freshmen and some new students that are here, my name is Leonetta Sanders. I am--
现在，再次向一年级新生和在座的一些新同学介绍，我叫莱奥内塔·桑德斯。我是——
On Friday of this week, President Obama went to a Chicago high school and spoke about all the shootings happening in our cities. We've all heard so much lately about kids getting shot. Last weekend, there was a funeral, 15-year-old Hadiya Pendleton, an honor student who was shot in a park in mid-afternoon in Chicago, just a week after performing at an inaugural event in Washington.
本周五，奥巴马总统去了芝加哥的一所高中，谈到了我们城市里发生的所有枪击事件。最近我们听到了太多关于孩子被枪杀的消息。上周末，举行了15岁的哈迪亚·彭德尔顿（Hadiya Pendleton）的葬礼，她是一名优等生，在芝加哥一个公园的午后被枪杀，而就在一周前，她还在华盛顿的就职典礼上表演过。
Last year the number of murders in Chicago rose while in many other big cities like New York and Los Angeles, it held steady or fell. It was 506 dead in Chicago last year. But of course, these deaths aren't evenly distributed all over the city. The majority are in a handful of neighborhoods, like this one.
去年芝加哥的谋杀案数量上升，而纽约和洛杉矶等许多其他大城市则保持平稳或下降。去年芝加哥有506人死亡。但当然，这些死亡并非均匀分布在整个城市。大多数发生在少数几个社区，就像这里。
This is Englewood. Police statistics show that it is one of the most dangerous areas of the city. Though, if you're picturing some kind of chaotic, depressing, ghetto high school in the middle of all of that, Harper is anything but. Amidst boarded up houses and vacant lots, it is a four story, yellow brick building. The grounds are neat and beautiful. The halls, walls, classrooms, cafeteria-- everything is well taken care of. There's order. Between passing periods, the halls are kept clear. It's clean. You can tell the staff likes the kids. Even the security guards-- there are 16 for a student body of just 550 or so. They joke around.
这里是恩格尔伍德（Englewood）。警察统计数据显示，这是该市最危险的地区之一。不过，如果你脑海中勾勒出的是那种身处乱世、令人沮丧、位于贫民窟中心的高中，哈珀完全不是那样。在被木板钉住的房屋和空地之间，这是一栋四层的黄色砖砌建筑。校园整洁美丽。走廊、墙壁、教室、食堂——一切都维护得很好。这里很有秩序。课间休息时，走廊保持畅通。这里很干净。你可以看出教职工很喜欢这些孩子。甚至连保安——550名左右的学生配有16名保安。他们会开玩笑。
Let's go, freshmen! Let's go! I have fresh meat. (LAUGHS) You can't be sleepy already. It just started.
快走，新生们！快走！我有新鲜的肉。（笑声）你们可不能现在就犯困。这才刚开始呢。
Principal Sanders sets the tone for the building. And just listen here to how she informs a girl who showed up on the first day of school out of uniform that the girl can never do that again.
桑德斯校长为这栋建筑定下了基调。请听听她是如何告诉一个开学第一天没穿校服的女孩，这种事绝不能再发生。
Oh, my God! You look so cute! Too bad you can't wear that white shirt. But you all look so cute!
天哪！你看起来真可爱！可惜你不能穿那件白衬衫。但你们看起来都好可爱！
That's classic Harper. You're reprimanded, but with love. One consequence of all the violence last year, Ms. Sanders and other administrators had to spend a certain amount of this first day back to school trying to convince worried parents that it is safe to send their kids back to school here this year. None of last year's shootings actually happened at the school.
这就是经典的哈珀风格。你受到了训斥，但充满了爱。去年所有暴力事件的一个后果是，桑德斯女士和其他行政人员不得不花费开学第一天的一部分时间，试图说服担心的家长，把孩子送回这里上学是安全的。去年的枪击事件实际上没有一起发生在学校内。
Can I talk to him on the phone?
我能在电话里和他谈谈吗？
Nuh uh. He don't want to come back.
不行。他不想回来。
This is assistant principal Chad Adams and a mom who wants to transfer her son out.
这是副校长查德·亚当斯（Chad Adams）和一位想让儿子转学的母亲。
He doesn't want to come back? But he's been with us for two years.
他不想回来？但他已经在我们这里待了两年了。
I know.
我知道。
And we've put so much time and work and love into him. We want him to stay.
我们在他身上投入了那么多的时间、工作和爱。我们希望他留下来。
I know.
我知道。
And what was the reason? You told me that grandmother said something. What was she saying again.
原因是什么？你告诉我他奶奶说了些什么。她是怎么说的？
She said she don't want him up here because the fighting and the stuff going on.
她说她不想让他来这儿，因为外面有打架和那些乱七八糟的事。
Is she worried about the killings?
她是担心杀戮吗？
Yep. That what she worried about.
是的。那就是她担心的。
And the people shooting at everyone?
还有那些向所有人开枪的人？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah. So even if we've got someone to come to his house every morning and pick him up, like, if I drove over to his house every morning and picked him up, you still wouldn't want him to come?
是啊。所以即使我们每天早上派人到他家接他，比如，如果我每天早上开车去他家接他，你还是不想让他来吗？
This is not, by the way, a theoretical question. Administrators do pick up some kids and drive them to school. Here at our radio show, we first heard about Harper this summer, when our colleague, Linda Lutton, who covers education at our home station, WBEZ in Chicago, did a story about the death of a 16-year-old sophomore named Shakaki Asphy, who played on the school's basketball team.
顺便说一句，这并非一个理论问题。行政人员确实会接一些孩子并开车送他们去学校。在我们的广播节目中，我们是在今年夏天第一次听说哈珀的。当时，我们报道教育的同事琳达·勒顿（Linda Lutton）在我们位于芝加哥的母台WBEZ做了一个故事，关于一名叫沙卡基·阿斯菲（Shakaki Asphy）的16岁高二女生的死亡，她是学校篮球队的成员。
Shakaki was shot while standing on a porch talking to a friend near the end of the school year. Her murder was such a blow to the staff and the students that even Principal Sanders-- who's been at the school for years and is definitely not easy to rattle-- even Principal Sanders said that it made her wonder if she could continue doing this work. She showed Linda this list that she'd been keeping, for a year at that point, of all the kids who had been shot from Harper. Shakaki was number 27.
沙卡基在学期末站在门廊和朋友说话时被枪杀。她的谋杀案对教职工和学生来说是一个沉重的打击，以至于连桑德斯校长——她在这所学校工作多年，绝不是那种容易被动摇的人——连她都说这让她怀疑自己是否还能继续做这份工作。她给琳达看了那份她保存了一年的名单，上面记录了所有从哈珀遭到枪击的孩子。沙卡基是第27个。
All of us here knew, of course, about the murders in Chicago. But when we heard Linda's story about this one school with 27 shootings, at that point, in a year, we thought this is a school that knows this problem in a way that most of us around the country never see, don't know. And we wondered, what if we spent a long period of time there, to witness what they're witnessing?
我们当然都知道芝加哥的谋杀案。但当我们听到琳达关于这所学校一年内发生27起枪击事件的故事时，我们想，这是一所对这个问题有着我们全国大多数人从未见过、不了解的认知的学校。我们想，如果我们在那里待上一段时间，去亲眼见证他们所见证的一切，会怎样？
Harper agreed to let us send three reporters in, starting at the beginning of this school year. And they gave us unusual access for more than five months, for a full semester. When violence struck, they let us record the administrators as the administrators jumped into action.
哈珀同意让我们派三名记者从本学年开始入驻。他们在超过五个月的时间里——整整一个学期——给了我们非同寻常的采访权限。当暴力事件发生时，他们让我们记录了行政人员在行动时的表现。
They let us into private, difficult meetings with parents and students. And we watched the staff try to recover from the terrible year that they had last year and try to make this year different. As you'll hear, they devote incredible energy to trying to keep their students alive.
他们让我们参加了私下且艰难的家长和学生会议。我们看着教职工试图从去年可怕的一年中恢复过来，并努力让今年变得不同。正如你将听到的，他们投入了难以置信的精力，试图保护他们的学生活着。
So much happened that we could not fit this all into one program. So what we're going to do is we're going to start our story at Harper this week. And we're going to continue it next week.
发生的事情太多了，我们无法将这一切塞进一个节目中。所以我们将从本周开始讲述我们在哈珀的故事。并将在下周继续。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. I hope you'll stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。希望你留下来继续收听。
So our reporters today and next week are Linda Lutton, who covers Chicago schools for our home station, WBEZ, like I said; Ben Calhoun, from our staff, who used to be a Chicago reporter; and Alex Kotlowitz, who's written many times over the years about violence in Chicago and its effect on kids growing up there. And let's just start. Let's start by jumping ahead a little ways into the school year for Act One, Rules to Live By, from Linda.
所以我们今天和下周的记者是琳达·勒顿（如我所说，她是WBEZ芝加哥学校报道的记者）、我们的员工本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun，他曾是芝加哥的记者），以及亚历克斯·科特洛维茨（Alex Kotlowitz，多年来多次撰写关于芝加哥暴力事件及其对成长中的孩子影响的文章）。让我们开始吧。让我们先跳到学年中段，开始第一幕《生存法则》（Rules to Live By），作者是琳达。
Two weeks after that first day assembly, Assistant Principal Chad Adams, the same guy you heard trying to convince a mom to re-enroll her kid in Harper this year, is in the hallways. He spots a sophomore, a new kid, a transfer student named Jordan.
开学典礼两周后，副校长查德·亚当斯（就是你刚才听到试图说服一位妈妈让孩子重返哈珀的那个人）正在走廊里。他发现了一名高二学生，一个转校来的新生，名叫乔丹（Jordan）。
So you were at Millburn? Did you know--
所以你在米尔本（Millburn）上学？你知道——
Mr. Adams tells Jordan he needs to talk to him in his office. There have been changes in his schedule, he says, though this is just a ploy. They go to his office. And Mr. Adams gets to the real purpose. He asks Jordan where he lives.
亚当斯先生告诉乔丹他需要去办公室和他谈谈。他说他的课程表有变动，尽管这只是个借口。他们来到办公室，亚当斯先生进入了正题。他问乔丹住哪儿。
69th and Loomis.
第69街和卢米斯大道（Loomis）。
69th and Loomis?
第69街和卢米斯？
Yeah.
是的。
So that way? Who's on that block?
那么那边呢？那条街区里谁说了算？
Like, what you mean?
什么意思？
You know. Who on that block? Who runs that block?
你知道的。那条街区里谁在？谁在那儿掌权？
What Mr. Adams is trying to figure out is what gang Jordan is affiliated with and what gangs he might potentially have conflicts with here at Harper. Without hesitating, Jordan tells Mr. Adams he's affiliated with a gang called Face World. And they're friendly with a half dozen other gangs. They're cliqued up, kids say.
亚当斯先生试图弄清楚乔丹隶属于哪个帮派，以及他在哈珀可能会与哪些帮派发生潜在冲突。乔丹没有犹豫，告诉亚当斯先生他属于一个叫“Face World”的帮派。他们和其他六七个帮派关系友好。孩子们说，他们是“结盟”的。
Well, we cliqued up with J-Town right there on 69th.
我们和第69街那边的J-Town结盟了。
Who else are y'all cliqued up with?
你们还和谁结盟了？
Hoodville, Low Block, Hit Squad, COB. We got a lot. A lot of people want to get into it with us, though, I ain't gonna lie.
Hoodville, Low Block, Hit Squad, COB。我们有很多盟友。不过说实话，很多人想和我们过不去。
I know. Your name was hot last spring. What was going on last spring?
我知道。你的名字去年春天很火。去年春天发生了什么？
It's a war zone around there. I can't lie. It's just a war zone.
那附近是个战区。我不能撒谎。那就是个战区。
People like us-- we so close to each other, it don't make no sense. 'Cause we right-- our opposition is right down the street. Literally, it's on the next block.
像我们这样的人——离得太近了，这根本没意义。因为我们的对手就在街那头。真的，就在下一个街区。
So, like, we on 70th and Rockwell, and they on 71st and Rockwell. That's how close we is. So--
我们住在第70街和洛克威尔（Rockwell），他们住在第71街和洛克威尔。我们就这么近。所以——
They talk about this for 15 minutes. And what's remarkable is how matter of fact it is. They might as well be talking about what bus Jordan needs to take home or where the cafeteria is. There's no shame to admitting your gang affiliation. It's nothing you have to keep a secret. Mr. Adams has one more goal for this meeting.
他们谈论了15分钟。引人注目的是这谈话是多么地客观平淡。他们就像在谈论乔丹需要坐哪路公交车回家，或者食堂在哪里一样。承认自己的帮派背景并没有什么可耻的。这不是你需要保密的事情。亚当斯先生这次会议还有一个目标。
All right. So I haven't met you yet because you weren't here last year. But I'm Mr. Adams. I'm the assistant principal. This is my office.
好了。我还没见过你，因为你去年不在这里。但我叫亚当斯先生。我是副校长。这是我的办公室。
All right, so can we make an agreement today that if something happens in the block, or something happens in the school, that you'll-- that you'll come to me to help you fix the problem? And we'll use this?
好的，我们今天能达成一个协议吗？如果街区里发生了什么，或者学校里发生了什么，你会——你会来找我，让我帮你解决问题？我们会动用这个？
Adams points to his head.
亚当斯指了指自己的头。
Look at me, Mr. Rogers. We'll use this, instead of this.
看着我，罗杰斯先生（Mr. Rogers）。我们要用这个，而不是用这个。
He points to his fists.
他指了指自己的拳头。
Can we make an agreement?
我们能达成协议吗？
See, I make an agreement, like, if something happened in school. Like, if something happened in school, I would probably come to you and tell you, like, what was going down. But outside is a whole different story.
看，如果学校里发生了什么事，我可以答应你，我会来告诉你发生了什么。但校外是完全不同的另一回事。
And I'm not saying that I'm going to be able to help you with your problems outside the school. I'm just saying if something happens on the block that might lead back into the building, that you'll come to me so we can fix it here, so you don't have to worry about it here.
我并不是说我能帮你解决校外的所有问题。我只是说，如果街区发生了可能蔓延到校内的事情，你会来找我，这样我们就能在这里解决，你就不必在这里担心它了。
Um, I'll try to keep my worrying on the outside and might keep that agreement. But it is probably going to be hard, though.
嗯，我会尽量把担心留在外面，可能会遵守那个协议。但那可能会很难。
OK. You know, and that's OK. I know it's going to be hard. It's not an easy agreement.
好的。我知道这会很难。这不是一个轻松的协议。
If it's-- if it's-- if I get into a problem with that [INAUDIBLE], if I get into a problem with one of [INAUDIBLE] people in this school, I ain't going to lie. I'm probably not even going to come here. I'll probably just go and do it right there, 'cause the problem escalated. 'Cause ain't no talking with them.
如果——如果我遇到了那个[听不清]的问题，如果我遇到了学校里的某些人，我不会撒谎的。我可能甚至不会来这儿了。我可能就直接去那边解决掉，因为问题升级了。因为和他们没什么好谈的。
Maybe you think you have an idea of how street gangs operate. Crips and Bloods, people and folks, controlling huge swaths of the city, shooting it out over drug territory, a single gang leader controlling thousands of members, a strictly enforced hierarchy branching out underneath him, with gang colors and hats tilted to the right or left. For this hour, forget all that.
也许你以为你知道街头帮派是如何运作的。瘸子帮（Crips）和血帮（Bloods）、人民帮（People）和民间帮（Folks），控制着城市大片地区，为了毒品地盘火拼，单一的帮派头目控制着数千名成员，有着严格执行的等级制度，还要戴着向左或向右倾斜的帮派颜色帽子。接下来的这一小时，忘掉所有那些。
The gangs in the Englewood neighborhood today are not those gangs. There's no central leader, no hierarchy, no colors. The fights aren't over drug territory. In fact, lots of these gangs aren't even selling drugs.
今天恩格尔伍德社区的帮派不是那些帮派。没有中央领导，没有等级制度，没有标志色。打架也不是为了毒品地盘。事实上，很多这样的帮派甚至不卖毒品。
They're different gangs with different rules. These rules apply absolutely to boys. Girls get slightly more leeway. Rule number one, look at a map.
它们是不同的帮派，有不同的规则。这些规则绝对适用于男孩。女孩则稍微宽松一点。规则一，看看地图。
When I ask kids what their parents don't understand about gangs these days, they say it's this. Their parents tell them not to join a gang, as if there's some initiation to go through, some way to sign up. Today, whether or not you want to be in a gang, you're in one.
当我问孩子们他们的父母对现在的帮派有什么不了解的地方时，他们说的是这个。他们的父母告诉他们不要加入帮派，好像那需要经过什么仪式，或者需要登记一样。今天，不管你想不想入伙，你都已经身在其中了。
If you live on pretty much any block near Harper High School, you have been assigned a gang. Your mother bought a house on 72nd and Hermitage? You're S Dub. You live across the street from the school? That's D-Ville.
如果你住在哈珀高中附近的任何一个街区，你就已经被分配了一个帮派。你妈妈在第72街和赫米蒂奇（Hermitage）买了一栋房子？你是S Dub帮的。你住在学校对面？那是D-Ville帮的。
When you ask kids or cops or school staff how it got like this, they'll tell you that at one point this whole area was controlled pretty much by a single gang, the Gangster Disciples. But, and this is how most people tell this part of the story, Chicago police have been so effective at locking up the big gang leaders that the hierarchy of those gangs has crumbled. And that's left a lot of room for newcomers.
当你问孩子、警察或学校教职工它是如何变成这样的，他们会告诉你，一度这个地区基本上是由一个单一的帮派——“黑帮门徒”（Gangster Disciples）控制的。但是——这是大多数人讲述这部分故事的方式——芝加哥警方在逮捕大型帮派头目方面非常有效，导致这些帮派的等级制度崩溃了。这给新人留下了很大的空间。
Your gang might control nothing more than the block you live on. In Harper's attendance area alone, which is a couple square miles, there are more than 15 gangs, also known as cliques, sets, factions, or crews. Some don't have anyone in charge.
你的帮派控制的可能只是你住的那个街区而已。仅在哈珀的生源区——几个平方英里——就有超过15个帮派，也被称为“小团体”（cliques）、“集合”（sets）、“派系”（factions）或“小队”（crews）。有些甚至没人负责。
But they do have guns. That's what every kid has told me. Otherwise, why would you call yourself a gang, they say.
但他们确实有枪。这是每个孩子告诉我的。他们说，不然你干嘛叫自己帮派？
Aaron Washington is a police officer assigned to Harper. He's there seven hours a day, seems to know every kid in the school. He says that for protection, for survival, kids walk to school with the kids in their clique, often through enemy territory.
亚伦·华盛顿（Aaron Washington）是一名分配到哈珀的警官。他每天在那里待七个小时，似乎认识学校里的每一个孩子。他说，为了保护自己，为了生存，孩子们会和他们小团体里的孩子一起步行去学校，经常穿过敌对地盘。
So I ask him, what if I'm a kid, and I really don't want any part of this gang stuff. How can I avoid it?
所以我问他，如果我是个孩子，我真的不想参与任何帮派的事情。我该怎么避开它？
You can't. It's not going to happen.
你避不开。那是不可能的。
He says it used to be possible to be neutral, what they called a neutron.
他说过去有可能保持中立，他们称之为“中子”（neutrons）。
There is no neutrons anymore. It used to be if you played sports or you were academically better than the average kid, they didn't bother you. Now it's different.
现在已经没有“中子”了。过去如果你参加体育运动或成绩比普通孩子好，他们就不会打扰你。现在不同了。
It doesn't matter. If you live here, you're part of them. You know, you live on that block, or you live in that area, you one of them.
没关系。如果你住在这里，你就是他们的一员。你知道，你住在那个街区，或者住在那个区域，你就是他们的人。
The way they get to school, they have to come to school with one of these factions, one of these gangs. They going to come to school with them. They don't have a choice.
他们去学校的方式，他们必须和一个派系、一个帮派一起去学校。他们会和他们一起去学校。他们没得选择。
I can hardly believe that a Chicago police officer is telling me this, admitting that kids don't have a choice about being gang affiliated. I've never heard police talk like this. Later I ask Officer Washington if he'll get in trouble for saying this. I mean, aren't cops supposed to just tell kids, hey, don't join a gang?
我几乎不敢相信一个芝加哥警察会告诉我这些，承认孩子们对是否加入帮派没得选择。我从未听过警察这样说话。后来我问华盛顿警官他这样说会不会惹麻烦。我是说，警察不应该只是告诉孩子，嘿，不要加入帮派吗？
I'll put it like this. I'm not saying it is OK to be in a gang. And I'm not saying I approve of it, I agree with it.
我这么说吧。我不是说加入帮派是可以的。我也不赞成，不认同它。
If I could take them all, and say, hey, look here, ain't no gangs, you know? I'd do that. But this ain't a fairy tale.
如果我能把他们都带走，说，嘿，听着，没有帮派，你知道吗？我会那样做。但这又不是童话故事。
And this is the point. Gangs aren't the bad kids in the corner here. They're the defining social structure in the school. It's who you sit with at lunch, the kids you say hi to in the hallway. It's the water everybody swims in.
重点就在这里。在这里，帮派不是角落里的坏孩子。它们是学校定义的社会结构。那是你午餐时坐在一起的人，是你在走廊里打招呼的孩子。这是每个人都在其中游动的“水”。
Assistant Principal Adams guesses that fewer than 10% of Harper students are actually gangbanging, that is, active on the block, involved in crime. He thinks all the rest of the kids in the school are just caught up by where they live.
副校长亚当斯估计，只有不到10%的哈珀学生在真正“混帮派”，即在街区活跃、参与犯罪。他认为学校里的其他孩子只是被他们居住的地方卷了进去。
OK. So rule number one is know your geography. Rule number two, never walk by yourself.
好的，规则一是要了解你的地理位置。规则二，永远不要单独行走。
[STREET NOISE]
[街道噪音]
One day at dismissal, I thought I saw a freshman walking home alone.
有一天放学时，我以为我看到一个一年级新生独自走回家。
I stopped you because you were walking by yourself.
我叫住你是为了因为你一个人在走。
But I was wrong.
但我错了。
We're walking with them.
我们正和他们一起走。
Larnell now pointed over his shoulder at a couple of girls about 15 feet back.
拉内尔（Larnell）指了指身后大约15英尺远的一对女孩。
So you're actually walking with the girls back there?
所以你其实是和那后面的女孩们一起走的？
Yeah, I always walk with people home.
对，我总是和人一起回家。
What's the advantage?
有什么好处吗？
It's not trying to get jumped on and shot. 'Cause they be fighting and shooting up there almost every day. Because won't nobody mess with somebody in a group, walking in a group.
为了不被袭击和枪击。因为他们几乎每天都在那儿打架和开枪。因为没人会去招惹一群一起走的人。
And that's true. But it's complicated, because of rule number three. Rule number three, never walk with someone else.
这是真的。但这很复杂，因为有规则三。规则三，永远不要和别人一起走。
See, walking in a group can send its own message. If you're with a group of boys in Englewood-- on your porch, walking home from school-- you're highlighting your affiliation, which makes you more of a target. It's a huge catch-22 for kids in this neighborhood. If you walk alone, you risk being jumped. If you walk with someone else, you risk being labeled as a gang member and being shot.
你看，一群人一起走也会传达一种信息。如果你在恩格尔伍德的一群男孩中——在你的门廊上，从学校回家——你就是在凸显你的所属关系，这让你成为了更大的目标。这对这个街区的孩子来说是一个巨大的“第22条军规”（进退两难）。如果你单独走，你冒着被袭击的风险。如果你和别人一起走，你冒着被贴上帮派成员标签并被枪击的风险。
Rule number four, don't use the sidewalk. Every day at dismissal, kids drift out of Harper High School and walk along Wood Street, actually, right down the middle of Wood Street. It's a strange scene.
规则四，不要走人行道。每天放学时，孩子们从哈珀高中出来，沿着伍德街（Wood Street）行走，实际上，就走在伍德街的正中央。这是一个奇怪的场景。
Cars drive slowly, waiting for students to move out of the way. One teacher told me that when she first arrived at Harper, she thought this was just plain hooliganism, the teenagers taking over. One afternoon, a girl named Alex explained, that's not it at all.
汽车缓慢行驶，等待学生们让路。一位老师告诉我，她刚到哈珀时，认为这简直是流氓行为，青少年们占领了街道。一天下午，一个叫亚历克斯（Alex）的女孩解释说，根本不是那回事。
We feel safer like this. For some reason, we just feel safe like that. We never like to walk past trees and stuff. There's too much stuff going on.
我们这样觉得更安全。出于某种原因，我们只是觉得那样更安全。我们从不喜欢走过树丛什么的。那里发生的事情太多了。
Too much stuff going on is shorthand here for the shootings, the fights, the craziness. It's better to walk down the middle of the street, where you can keep a broad view of things, and where you have a few more seconds to run if you need to. Rule number five, if they shoot, don't run.
“发生的事情太多了”在这里是对枪击、打架和疯狂事件的委婉说法。最好走在街道中央，在那里你可以保持广阔的视野，而且如果你需要跑，你会有几秒钟的时间。规则五，如果他们开枪，不要跑。
12th grader Antoryio was on the Harper High School football team. In fact, he's one of the best running backs in the entire city of Chicago. On the field, he zips around linemen like they're not even there, cutting and weaving, and then racing for the end zone. Those are skills he purposefully ignores when shot at.
12年级的安托里奥（Antoryio）是哈珀高中橄榄球队的成员。事实上，他是整个芝加哥最好的跑卫之一。在赛场上，他绕过防守队员，仿佛他们根本不存在，切割、穿梭，然后直冲终点区。当被开枪射击时，他刻意忽略了这些技巧。
I fall to the ground.
我趴在地上。
That's your strategy?
那是你的策略？
Yeah, 'cause you run, you'll probably get shot in the back or something like that. So I just fall to the ground. Most people, like, shoot from, like-- say, we, like, in front of my house, they'd shoot from the corner. Or do a drive-by in their cars, so I just fall to the ground.
对，因为如果你跑，你很可能会背部中弹什么的。所以我只是趴在地上。大多数人，就像——说吧，我们在我家门前，他们会从拐角处开枪。或者在车里开车枪击，所以我只是趴在地上。
OK. By now you may be wondering, if these gangs aren't fighting over drug territory, what are the shootings about? That brings us to rule number six. Rule number six, you can be shot for reasons big and small.
好的。到现在你可能在想，如果这些帮派不是为了毒品地盘而战，那枪击是为了什么？这让我们想到了规则六。规则六，你可能因为大事小事被枪杀。
If you ask the police or school officials or kids what the shootings are about, they'll mention girls, money owed. There was a paintball incident that led to real guns going off. Petty stuff, like losing a fist fight, he-said she-said arguments, often they'll tell you a shooting is over nothing.
如果你问警察、学校官员或孩子们枪击是为了什么，他们会提到女孩、欠款。有一个彩弹枪事件导致了真正的枪支走火。琐碎的事情，比如输了一场拳架，口角争执，他们经常告诉你枪击是为了“没什么”。
Retaliation for earlier shootings is a big reason for getting shot. Shootings can ping pong back and forth between rival gangs for years. Of course, you can also be shot for walking off your block.
为了之前的枪击而报复是中枪的一个大原因。枪击可以在敌对帮派之间反复发生，持续多年。当然，你也会因为离开了你的街区而被枪杀。
And finally, rule number seven, never go outside. When I ask kids for advice about staying alive in this neighborhood, they told me the best advice was to stay away from your block as long as possible every day. Get involved in something at school so you can stay as late as they let you.
最后，规则七，永远不要去外面。当我问孩子们关于在这个街区保持活命的建议时，他们告诉我最好的建议是每天尽可能远离你的街区。参加学校里的活动，这样你就可以尽量待到很晚。
When you do go home, don't leave the house. Don't even go on the porch. If you want to see the lengths you have to go to not be part of the gang, you should meet a senior named Deonte. Being anti-gang is Deonte's entire identity.
当你确实回家时，不要离开房子。甚至不要去门廊。如果你想看看为了不成为帮派一部分所必须采取的手段，你应该见见一个叫德翁特（Deonte）的高年级学生。反对帮派是德翁特身份的全部。
He's an outspoken Christian. He holds Bible study in his living room. Other kids come to him for advice, a role he wholly embraces. He's poised to be the valedictorian. When you talk to Deonte, you get a sense of what it takes to stay away from the gangs.
他是一位直言不讳的基督徒。他在客厅里举办圣经学习班。其他孩子来向他寻求建议，他完全接受了这个角色。他有望成为毕业典礼演讲人。当你和德翁特交谈时，你会感受到远离帮派需要付出什么。
Do you ever go out, like just around the neighborhood?
你出去过吗，就在街区附近？
Oh, no. Not at all, and in a way, that can be bad as well. Because that's when depression is easy to set in. That took a hold on me, 'cause I've been in the house for about three years. I've been staying in the house a lot.
哦，不。一点也没有，而且在某种程度上，那也可能很糟糕。因为那是抑郁症最容易侵入的时候。这对我产生了影响，因为我已经在家里待了大约三年了。我大部分时间都待在家里。
Do you feel lonely?
你感到孤独吗？
At times. At times, I feel lonely. At times, I would want to have some friends. 'Cause I'm not really friends with anybody.
有时。有时，我感到孤独。有时，我想要一些朋友。因为我和任何人都不算是真正的朋友。
If you think about high school, how important friends are during that time, imagine going through that with your whole goal being to avoid your school's social structure completely for four years. It's an incredibly high price to steer clear of the violence. It's a price most teenagers anywhere would find almost impossible to pay.
如果你想想高中，那个时期朋友有多重要，想象一下，带着整个目标——即在四年里完全避开学校的社会结构——来度过这段时期。为了远离暴力，这付出了极其高昂的代价。这是大多数青少年在任何地方都会发现几乎无法支付的代价。
Linda Lutton. Act Two, a Tiny Office on the Second Floor. So the place in the school where staff deals most directly with the effects of the violence on students is the social work office, as you'd kind of expect. Alex Kotlowitz has this story about one of the students that the social workers took under their wings.
琳达·勒顿（Linda Lutton）。第二幕，二楼的一个小办公室。所以，学校里处理暴力对学生影响最直接的地方是社会工作办公室，正如你所预料的那样。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨（Alex Kotlowitz）讲了这个故事，关于社会工作者庇护下的一名学生。
I first met Devonte, a junior, back on the first day of school when he and his mom came in for a meeting with Principal Sanders. Devonte was a Harper student who had been temporarily transferred and was now just returning. Sanders was happy to see him, but everyone seemed a little tense, a little careful. I couldn't tell exactly what was going on.
我第一次见到德翁特（Devonte），一个高二学生，是在开学第一天，当时他和妈妈来参加与桑德斯校长的会议。德翁特曾是一名暂时转学的哈珀学生，现在正准备回来。桑德斯很高兴见到他，但每个人看起来都有点紧张，有点小心翼翼。我无法准确判断发生了什么。
And we're not going to push you to get into any activities. Just, you know, you take your time right now. Just get back into the swing of school. 'Cause we starting a whole fresh slate here.
我们不会强迫你参加任何活动。只要，你知道，现在花点时间。只要重新适应学校的节奏。因为我们在这里开启了一个全新的开始。
It was only later that I learned the full story. That last February, Devonte accidentally shot and killed his 14-year-old brother. After the shooting, the Harper staff had been concerned that kids might taunt Devonte, so he was transferred to a different school.
直到后来我才得知完整的故事。去年二月，德翁特意外开枪打死了他14岁的弟弟。枪击事件后，哈珀的教职工担心孩子们可能会嘲讽德翁特，所以他被转到了另一所学校。
Now that he was back, a few weeks into school, he's been stopping by the school social worker's office two or three times a day to meet with one of the social workers there, Crystal Smith.
现在他回来了，开学几周后，他每天两三次到学校社会工作者的办公室，与其中一名社会工作者克里斯托·史密斯（Crystal Smith）会面。
Close that door for me, [INAUDIBLE]. Because you know, I don't what people, you know, walking by, all up in our conversation and stuff, you know?
帮我关上那扇门，[听不清]。因为你知道，我不想让人，你知道，走来走去，插嘴我们的谈话什么的，你知道吗？
Mhm.
嗯。
Is that OK?
可以吗？
The shooting happened last winter, after school. Devonte says his brother had somehow gotten his hands on an old handgun, which neither of them thought worked. In their third floor apartment, they both handled the weapon. While Devonte was holding it, it somehow went off.
枪击发生在去年冬天放学后。德翁特说他的弟弟以某种方式弄到了一把旧手枪，他们俩都以为它不能用。在三楼的公寓里，他们都拿了那把武器。当德翁特握着它时，它不知怎么就走火了。
A judge later ruled it an accident-- reckless discharge of a firearm. Devonte's brother Damion died an hour later in the hospital. Devonte hasn't had any intensive counseling since the shooting. So for Crystal, establishing a relationship with him is tricky.
法官后来裁定这是一起意外——鲁莽开枪。德翁特的弟弟达米恩（Damion）一小时后在医院去世。枪击事件后，德翁特没有接受过任何密集的心理辅导。所以对于克里斯托来说，与他建立关系很棘手。
What you eat for lunch? How you going to not let me share it with you?
你午饭吃了什么？你打算怎么不让我和你分享？
I ate, um, chicken patties.
我吃了，嗯，鸡肉饼。
To make him feel safe enough with her to talk about his feelings, and most importantly about his guilt, she often bounces around in their meetings from totally superficial things, like lunch, to more substantive subjects, like Devonte smoking marijuana. He tells Crystal he hasn't smoked in a while. And she does an impression of him when he's high.
为了让他感到足够安全可以和她谈论自己的感受，尤其是关于他的内疚，她在会议中经常从完全肤浅的事情（比如午餐）跳跃到更实质性的主题（比如德翁特抽大麻）。他告诉克里斯托他已经有一段时间没抽了。她模仿了他吸大麻后的样子。
When you're smoking, you be, like, (SLURRING) what's up, Miss Smith? I'd be like, dude, you know you high, right? (SLURRING) Naw, I'm straight. [LAUGHS] That'd be you. You don't even be remembering that we done had a conversation, do you?
当你抽的时候，你就像，（口齿不清）嘿，史密斯小姐？我会说，伙计，你知道你嗨了吧，对吧？（口齿不清）不，我很清醒。[笑声]那会是你。你甚至都不记得我们刚才谈过话了，是吧？
No.
不。
It's OK, though.
没关系。
I know-- I do, I do remember this one, though.
我知道——但我确实记得这一件。
What?
什么？
To my moms, who might throw my little brother's bed away, and I don't want her to throw it away and stuff.
对我妈，她可能会把小弟弟的床扔掉，我不希望她把它扔掉什么的。
He's worried his mom might throw away his little brother's bed.
他担心他妈妈可能会扔掉他弟弟的床。
So we talked about-- can I say this? It helps him to sleep at night if he sleeps in his brother's bed. But his mother was contemplating throwing the bed away. And so I had told him that if I needed to, I would call her and let her know why it's important for him to be able to, you know, keep the bed. Right?
所以我们谈到了——我可以这么说吗？如果他睡在他弟弟的床上，这有助于他在晚上睡觉。但他母亲正在考虑把那张床扔掉。所以我告诉他，如果有必要，我会给她打电话，让她知道为什么他能保留那张床很重要。对吧？
Mhm.
嗯。
You still with me?
你还在听吗？
Yeah, I'm with you.
是的，我在听。
If it's too much, you just say, I'm done.
如果太沉重了，你就说，我受不了了。
Nah, it ain't too much.
不，那不沉重。
OK.
好的。
The day after his brother's funeral, Devonte showed up at Harper wearing a t-shirt with a picture of his brother on it. There were food stains on the shirt, leading Crystal to believe he'd probably slept in it. Crystal says before the shooting, Devonte barely came to school. He was aggressive and surly with the staff.
在他弟弟葬礼后的第二天，德翁特穿着一件印有他弟弟照片的T恤来到哈珀。衬衫上有食物污渍，导致克里斯托认为他可能穿着它睡了觉。克里斯托说在枪击事件前，德翁特几乎不来学校。他对教职工很暴躁。
But here he was, the day after burying his brother. And Crystal realized that Devonte needed to be at Harper, that he needed her. She's still just at the beginning of figuring out what she can do for Devonte. He's cracked the door, she told me, but it's the size of a mouse hole.
但就在这里，在他安葬弟弟后的第二天。克里斯托意识到德翁特需要哈珀，他需要她。她现在只是刚开始搞清楚她能为德翁特做什么。他已经打开了那扇门，她告诉我，但它只有老鼠洞那么大。
I spent most of my time at Harper in the social work office. Crystal has a caseload of 55 kids, each of whom struggles with a learning disability or some kind of emotional issue. Another part-time social worker and a school psychologist also have a caseload of kids. But they make strong personal connections with lots of Harper students, not just those they're assigned to. And more often than not, because of some violent incident.
我在哈珀的大部分时间都在社会工作办公室。克里斯托负责55个孩子，每个孩子都有学习障碍或某种情绪问题。另一位兼职社会工作者和一名学校心理学家也负责一批孩子。但他们与许多哈珀学生建立了深厚的个人联系，不仅仅是他们负责的那些。而且往往是因为某种暴力事件。
Harper, of course, has just come off this horribly violent year. And I guess the question I had, and honestly, the question that the social workers ask themselves is, can they make a difference?
当然，哈珀刚刚经历了这一极度暴力的一年。我想我有一个问题，老实说，也是社会工作者问自己的问题是，他们能带来改变吗？
[SCHOOL HALL CHATTER]
[学校走廊的嘈杂声]
Hello! How are you? [INAUDIBLE]. Hi, Shari!
你好！你好吗？[听不清]。嗨，莎莉！
Crystal is in the halls for every passing period with a constant patter of positivity.
克里斯托在每个课间休息时间都在走廊里，不断散发着积极向上的氛围。
I'm so proud of you. I see you trying hard. Keep it up, OK? I'm so proud of you! Go, go, go! So you won't be late. Go, go, go! Y'all moving around, right?
我为你感到骄傲。我看到你很努力。继续保持，好吗？我为你感到骄傲！走吧，走吧，走吧！这样你才不会迟到。走吧，走吧，走吧！你们都在动起来，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
Thank you so much. Let me appreciate you in advance.
非常感谢。让我预先感谢你。
I appreciate you in advance, a phrase I've never heard anyone use before, is one of Crystal's trademarks.
“我预先感谢你”，这句我从未听过别人使用的话，是克里斯托的招牌之一。
Do you have your headphones in while you're talking to me?
你在和我说话时戴着耳机吗？
I'm not-- it's low.
我没——声音很小。
Is it off? Could you take them out so I won't feel like I'm being disrespected?
关了吗？你能取下来吗，这样我就不会觉得我不被尊重了？
I'm not.
我没戴。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
It ain't nothing playing.
什么都没在放。
I appreciate you in advance. Terrell, how was your summer?
我预先感谢你。特雷尔（Terrell），你暑假过得怎么样？
It was OK, safe.
还行，安全。
Safe?
安全？
Yeah.
对。
That's great. You're the only person that said that to me. That means something to me. I'm glad it was safe. Good morning, gentlemen. Good morning.
太棒了。你是唯一一个这么对我说的。这对我意义重大。我很高兴它是安全的。早上好，先生们。早上好。
Even when a kid characterizes his summer not as fun or relaxing, but as safe, Crystal sees the bright side. I've seen her practically tackle students to tell them, you're a valuable person. You matter. When she's doling out advice, some of the kids laughingly call it Mom Patrol. Sometimes, though, I wonder if the kids see past her perkiness. Because she's really a force.
即使当一个孩子形容他的夏天不是有趣或放松，而是“安全”时，克里斯托也能看到光明的一面。我见过她几乎扑上去告诉学生：你是一个有价值的人。你很重要。当她分发建议时，一些孩子笑着称之为“妈妈巡逻队”。然而，有时我想知道孩子们是否看穿了她的活泼。因为她确实是一股力量。
I thank you for being to class on time. Thank you! I love you!
我感谢你们准时上课。谢谢！我爱你们！
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[不同声音交叉]
I'm up out of here. I'm fixing to go to class.
我要离开这里了。我正准备去上课。
It's six weeks later, late September, and the social work office is packed. All times of day, kids pile into the social work office, a crowded, windowless room stuffed with three desks, a filing cabinet, and a paper shredder. So many kids that at times you have to jostle for a place to stand.
六周后，九月下旬，社会工作办公室挤满了人。一天中的所有时间，孩子们都涌入社会工作办公室，一个拥挤、没有窗户、塞着三张桌子、一个档案柜和一个碎纸机的房间。人多的时候，你不得不为站立的地方挤来挤去。
Some of the kids come because their educational plans mandate social work visits. And others come just because they like talking with Crystal and Anita Stewart, the school's other social worker. Devonte is often in the office.
有些孩子来是因为他们的教育计划强制要求社会工作访问。其他人来只是因为他们喜欢和克里斯托以及安妮塔·斯图尔特（Anita Stewart，学校的另一位社会工作者）交谈。德翁特经常在办公室。
Before the incident last February where Devonte accidentally shot his 14-year-old brother, he didn't have much of a relationship with Crystal or Anita. But now, they're really getting close. Earlier in the year, Devonte had told them he wasn't sleeping well. And today, Anita and Crystal want to talk about it.
在去年二月德翁特意外枪杀他14岁弟弟的事件之前，他与克里斯托或安妮塔没有多少交际。但现在，他们真的变得亲密了。年初，德翁特告诉他们他睡得不好。今天，安妮塔和克里斯托想谈谈这个。
So what about sleeping and all of that, Devonte? Are you sleeping OK?
那么睡觉什么的怎么样，德翁特？你睡得还好吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
What you do at night to help you though?
你晚上做了什么来帮助你？
To go to sleep? I take some Nyquil.
睡觉？我喝点尼奎尔（Nyquil）。
Oh, you still taking Nyquil?
哦，你还在喝尼奎尔？
Man, I take it on a regular base. 'Cause I need to go to sleep, man.
伙计，我经常喝。因为我需要睡觉，伙计。
So we need to talk about--
所以我们需要谈谈——
I need to sleep tight.
我需要睡个好觉。
What happens if you don't take the Nyquil?
如果你不喝尼奎尔会怎样？
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
I don't go to sleep.
我睡不着。
Can I ask you a question? What are the thoughts that you have when you get ready to go to sleep?
我能问你一个问题吗？当你准备睡觉时，你会有什么想法？
None.
没有。
You having some kind thoughts that you're trying to escape. So that that way--
你有一些你试图逃避的想法。所以那样的话——
I just be up thinking about stuff.
我只是躺着想事情。
What? One thought that you be thinking about?
什么？你一直在想的一个想法？
One, my brother. I be thinking about a lot of stuff.
一个，我弟弟。我一直在想很多事情。
He's thinking about his brother. Devonte tells Crystal and Anita that he looks at pictures of Damion, his brother, every night before going to bed. He shows them the pictures on his phone. One is a school portrait. Another is of Damion in his casket, dressed in a blue suit and a crisp white shirt.
他在想他的弟弟。德翁特告诉克里斯托和安妮塔，他每天睡觉前都会看他弟弟达米恩的照片。他给他们看手机上的照片。一张是毕业照。另一张是达米恩在棺材里，穿着蓝色西装和洁白衬衫的样子。
He look like me in this casket, like I'm asleep.
他在棺材里看起来像我，就像我睡着了一样。
Mama's got it in her phone, too.
妈妈手机里也有。
You saw it in her phone?
你在她手机里看到的？
'Cause she showed it to me. Remember, we had the meeting?
因为她给我看了。记得吗，我们开过会？
Devonte, do you feel like your family is supporting you with this?
德翁特，你觉得你的家人在这方面支持你吗？
With what?
支持什么？
What happened to your brother?
你弟弟发生的事？
Nah, don't nobody talk about it. Don't nobody talk or nothing. Don't nobody say nothing.
不，没人谈论它。没人谈论什么。没人说什么。
Just everybody just go around like it just didn't happen?
大家只是表现得好像那件事没发生过一样？
Mhm.
嗯。
Because you know it happened, because you look at the picture every night.
因为你知道它发生了，因为你每天晚上都看那张照片。
Yeah.
是的。
Devonte also has a video of his brother. He huddles with Crystal and Anita, watching it on his phone. It's of three boys, clearly high, hanging out in a kitchen, cracking jokes and laughing. Damion's off to one side, sitting on the floor.
德翁特还有一个他弟弟的视频。他缩在一起和克里斯托、安妮塔一起，在手机上看着它。视频里有三个男孩，显然很高，在厨房里混，开着玩笑笑得前仰后合。达米恩在一边，坐在地板上。
This is your brother here, right?
这是你弟弟，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[INAUDIBLE]. I'm talking about you. [INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。我说的是你。[听不清]。
He was a little strong little boy.
他是个强壮的小男孩。
Yeah, he look, you could tell.
对，他看起来，你感觉得出来。
[INAUDIBLE]. Dumb bitches.
[听不清]。蠢货。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Crystal and Anita are hoping to start a trauma group with Devonte and three other boys at Harper, who are also struggling because of the violence. Devonte's noncommittal. Crystal seems almost desperate to get Devonte to see the importance of talking about his experience.
克里斯托和安妮塔希望能和德翁特以及哈珀的其他三个男孩开始一个创伤小组，他们也因为暴力事件而挣扎。德翁特不置可否。克里斯托看起来几乎绝望地想让德翁特明白谈论他的经历的重要性。
Can I just tell you-- can I say that again? At some point, though, because you are a junior, and we only got one more year, we going to have to start being able to talk about that, so that that way, we can start helping you get through the process of that.
我能告诉你——我可以再说一遍吗？但到某个时候，因为你是个高二学生，我们只剩一年了，我们必须开始能够谈论那件事，这样我们才能开始帮助你度过那个过程。
It's something [INAUDIBLE].
那是[听不清]。
You going to have to feel safe somewhere to talk about it.
你得在某个地方感到安全才能谈论它。
I feel safe wherever I'm at.
我无论在哪儿都感到安全。
I feel safe wherever I'm at, he says.
我无论在哪儿都感到安全，他说。
I'm talking about the stuff with your brother. I'm talking about the stuff that make you take the Nyquil at night, that you not talking to nobody about.
我是在说你弟弟的事。我是在说那些让你晚上喝尼奎尔的事，你没跟任何人谈过。
If you feel closer [INAUDIBLE].
如果你感到亲近[听不清]。
That's the weight that you have to-- do you know what it's like to carry weight?
那就是你不得不背负的重量——你知道背负重量是什么感觉吗？
No, no, for real. Don't nobody know every day you feel like this. And it's just, like, can't nobody see it. But then, I can't-- you know what I'm saying? I see it, and I know it.
不，不，说真的。没人知道你每天感觉像这样。那就像，没人能看到它。但后来，我不能——你知道我在说什么吗？我看到了，我知道它。
But then, I don't know if you ready-- you see what I'm saying--
但后来，我不知道你是否准备好了——你明白我在说什么吗——
--to help get some of it off. I understand-- I'm saying I'm with you on what the weight feels like.
——去帮着减轻一点。我明白——我是说，我明白那种重量是什么感觉，我和你站在一起。
Ms. Grant, first, I just want to check with you and just see how you doing.
格兰特太太，首先，我只想看看你，看看你怎么样。
I'm fine. I'm all right.
我很好。我还可以。
Doing all right?
还可以？
Yeah, taking it one day at a time.
对，过一天是一天。
That's all you can do.
你只能那样做了。
Yep.
对。
One day after school in the last week of September, it's report card day at Harper. And Devonte's mom, Ms. Grant, is the first parent in the building. Crystal makes a point of seeking her out and asks if they can sit and talk at a table in the cafeteria. Anita joins them. Devonte is actually doing reasonably well. He's getting B's and C's in all of his classes, except for music, which he's failing. These are his best grades since he began high school.
九月最后一周的一天下午，是哈珀的成绩单日。德翁特的妈妈格兰特太太是第一个到校的家长。克里斯托特意去找她，并问她们是否可以坐在食堂的桌边谈谈。安妮塔加入了她们。德翁特的表现实际上相当不错。他除了音乐课不及格，其他所有科目都拿到了B和C。这是他上高中以来最好的成绩。
I want to tell you just how first, impressed I am with Devonte's academic and social, emotional growth, like, since the accident happened.
我首先想告诉你，我对德翁特自事故发生以来的学术和社会、情感成长印象有多深。
He came a long way.
他进步很大。
He has a really, really, Mother, come a long way. Like, he is so much more open with me now. And I just want you to know what we're going to continue to work on, which is the guilt that he feels about the accident.
他真的，真的，妈妈，进步很大。他现在对我开放多了。我只是想让你知道我们将继续努力的方向，也就是他关于事故感到的内疚。
Mhm.
嗯。
On the night of the shooting, Ms. Grant was sitting in her car outside of her building. Devonte was with Damion in the third floor apartment, their sister in another room. After the gun went off, Devonte sprinted downstairs to his mom, yelling, Mama, call an ambulance. I accidentally shot Damion.
枪击那天晚上，格兰特太太正坐在大楼外的车里。德翁特和达米恩在三楼公寓，妹妹在另一个房间。枪走火后，德翁特冲下楼告诉妈妈，“妈妈，叫救护车。我不小心打中了达米恩。”
Ms. Grant says she ran upstairs and saw Damion on the floor, no blood, just not moving. Ms. Grant says the police held her in the apartment while the ambulance took Damion to the hospital. He died before she arrived. Ms. Grant was only able to spend a little bit of time with Damion's body before she was told she was needed at the police station. Since Devonte was a minor, his mom had to be present for his questioning.
格兰特太太说她跑上楼看到达米恩在地板上，没有血，只是不动了。格兰特太太说警察把她扣在公寓里，而救护车把达米恩送去了医院。他在她到达之前就去世了。格兰特太太在被告知需要去警察局之前，只和达米恩的尸体待了一小会儿。由于德翁特未成年，他的母亲必须在场协助讯问。
I had met privately with Ms. Grant a week or so before the report card meeting with Crystal. She told me that an autopsy report concluded that Damion had been shot in the chest. In our interview then, as in the meeting with Crystal, Ms. Grant seemed to vacillate between being certain the shooting was a complete accident, and then being not so certain.
我在与克里斯托进行成绩单会议前一周左右私下见过格兰特太太。她告诉我，尸检报告总结说达米恩是被击中胸部。在当时的采访中，就像在与克里斯托的会议中一样，格兰特太太似乎在“这是一场彻底的意外”和“不那么确定”之间摇摆。
I can't turn my back on Devonte because Devonte my child, too. Being angry at him is not going to bring Damion back.
我不能背弃德翁特，因为德翁特也是我的孩子。对他生气带不回达米恩。
Right.
对。
You know, I feel-- I know that they wouldn't hurt each other like that. That's one thing I do know. Even though, you know, even-- you still don't know what happened. Even though I really, really, truly don't know what happened. You know, the autopsy report say it's one thing, and my heart say I don't know.
你知道，我感到——我知道他们不会那样伤害彼此。那是唯一我确定的。即使，你知道，即使——你仍然不知道发生了什么。即使我真的，真的，真心不知道发生了什么。你知道，尸检报告说是一回事，但我的心说我不知道。
Ms. Grant tells Crystal she knows she's hurt Devonte's feelings since Damion's death, and she feels bad about it. She says the night of the funeral, the adults went to a bar. When she got back to the apartment, Devonte overheard her saying, I believe Devonte shot my baby. She didn't know he was listening.
格兰特太太告诉克里斯托，她知道自达米恩去世后她伤了德翁特的心，她对此感到难过。她说葬礼那天晚上，大人们去了一个酒吧。当她回到公寓时，德翁特偷听到她说：“我相信德翁特枪杀了我的孩子。”她不知道他在偷听。
He got up and he slammed the door. He text me, I'm going to be with my brother. Forget all of y'all. I ain't do nothing to my brother to hurt my brother. And I felt so bad 'cause I-- he had-- it was about 3:00 in the morning. And he left. I ain't do nothing to my brother. I'm going where my brother is. You know, he kind of scared me.
他站起来，摔了门。他给我发短信说：“我要去和我弟弟待在一起。忘掉你们所有人。我没做任何事伤害我的弟弟。”我感到非常难过，因为我——他有——当时大约凌晨3点。他离开了。“我没做任何事伤害我的弟弟。我要去我弟弟所在的地方。”你知道，他把我吓坏了。
Then I text him back, go on ahead. You grown anyway. So? Go on ahead. You know, I text him back that.
然后我给他回短信说，“走吧。反正你长大了。所以？走吧。”你知道，我给他回了那个。
But he was mad. He was mad at me for that. Y'all thinking I hurt Damion. What makes y'all think I hurt my brother?
但他很生气。他因为那个对我生气。“你们以为我伤害了达米恩。是什么让你们以为我伤害了我弟弟？”
I'm going to state the obvious, but life at home for Devonte has got to be really, really hard. Ms. Grant, who works part-time in food service at a local Naval base, says that many days she cries alone in her room. She says Devonte's older sister, who lives with the family, won't talk to Devonte anymore. At one point, Ms. Grant told Crystal, the house was like hell.
我要说点显而易见的，但德翁特在家里的生活肯定非常非常艰难。格兰特太太在当地海军基地从事兼职餐饮服务，她说很多天她都在房里独自哭泣。她说德翁特和家人住在一起的姐姐不再和德翁特说话了。有一次，格兰特太太告诉克里斯托，家里简直像地狱。
Devonte has basically two places to escape to-- the streets or school. And on the streets, Devonte made clear to Crystal and to me, it's hard to relax, to let your guard down. He hangs with a lot of older guys, he says. And just a few weeks before this, a friend was shot right in front of him. So that really leaves just school-- more specifically, this office-- as a place where he can be himself and try to move on.
德翁特基本上有两个逃避的地方——街道或学校。而在街道上，德翁特向克里斯托和我明确表示，很难放松，很难放下防备。他说他经常和很多年长的人混在一起。就在几周前，一个朋友就在他面前被枪杀。所以这就只剩下学校——更具体地说是这个办公室——作为他可以做自己并试图继续前进的地方。
Alex Kotlowitz. We'll return to Devonte next week, when our story on Harper continues for a second hour. A lot happens to Devonte as the year unfolds. Coming up in today's show, homecoming, and a game that is even bigger than homecoming. That's in a minute.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨。我们将于下周回到德翁特的故事，届时我们在哈珀的故事将继续一小时。随着这一年的展开，德翁特身上发生了许多事。在今天的节目中，即将到来的是返校节，以及一场比返校节还要盛大的比赛。稍后回来。
Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，节目继续。
This American Life with Ira Glass. This is the first of two hours that we are bringing you from Harper High School in Chicago, where we had three reporters this school year. Last year, Harper had eight students murdered and 21 others wounded by gun violence.
《美国生活》与艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们为你带来的两小时关于芝加哥哈珀高中的第一小时，我们在本学年派了三名记者。去年，哈珀有八名学生被谋杀，另有21人因枪支暴力受伤。
These were current and recent students. We include recent students in these numbers, because as you'll see, the kids who drop out or transfer away are still connected to the kids who go to Harper. So when they are shot or something happens to them, it can have a huge impact on the school. We've arrived at Act Three of our program.
这些是在读和刚毕业的学生。我们把刚毕业的学生计入这些数字，因为正如你将看到的，辍学或转学的孩子仍然与哈珀的学生相连。所以当他们被枪击或发生什么事时，它会对学校产生巨大的影响。我们来到了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Game Plan. So we pick up our story right now at the beginning of October, homecoming week. The football team is something that is going very, very right at Harper High School. They are 5 and 0 at this point in the year. Though, of course, this still is Harper. What happens in the neighborhood still affects the team.
第三幕，比赛计划。所以我们现在在十月初，返校节周。橄榄球队是哈珀高中目前非常非常顺利的一件事。他们本年目前5胜0负。尽管，当然，这里仍然是哈珀。社区里发生的事仍然影响着球队。
When we started reporting here in the school we expected to find some football players who had been touched by gun violence. We really did not anticipate answers like this next one that Linda got.
当我们开始在这里报道时，我们希望找到一些经历过枪支暴力影响的橄榄球运动员。我们真的没有预料到琳达会得到下一个这样的答案。
Who do you know in football who has been either shot or shot at?
你认识的橄榄球队员里谁被枪击过或被枪击过？
Probably the whole team except freshmen and sophomore.
可能除了新生和高二生之外的整个球队。
Yeah, I think everybody was shot at since my four years being there. Yeah, everybody on the team.
是的，我认为自从我在这里待的四年里，每个人都被枪击过。是的，球队里的每个人。
That's number 11, junior Rodney Jackson, and number 4, Antoryio Barton. A player named Sandillio Wright was shot at one day and then played a game the next day. Harper's quarterback Kwame Ware was actually hit a few years back, shot in the leg.
那是11号，高三生罗德尼·杰克逊（Rodney Jackson），和4号，安托里奥·巴顿（Antoryio Barton）。一个叫桑迪利奥·赖特（Sandillio Wright）的球员有一天被枪击，第二天还踢了一场比赛。哈珀的四分卫夸梅·威尔（Kwame Ware）几年前也中过招，腿部中弹。
One of this year's recruits had a bullet go in the front of his leg and come out the back. He's slower now, he says. But he can still cut.
今年的新队员之一的腿部被一颗子弹贯穿。他说他现在慢了。但他依然能切入进攻。
About half the kids on the team are affiliated with one gang. There are five or six other gangs represented on the team, some of them opposition. But football actually seems to be the one place at Harper where everybody truly puts those rivalries aside. Ben Calhoun was at Harper for homecoming week.
队里大约一半的孩子与一个帮派有关。队里还有五六个其他帮派的代表，其中一些是敌对的。但橄榄球实际上似乎是哈珀唯一一个每个人真正能把那些竞争放在一边的地方。本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）在哈珀报道返校周。
At this point in the school year, Harper had been pretty violence free. There had been some fights, some big ones. But week after week was going by without a shooting. This was something that people, especially staff, they talked about it in this careful way, like they didn't want to jinx it.
在学年的这个阶段，哈珀几乎没有暴力事件。发生过一些打架，有些还是大的。但一周又一周过去了，没有发生枪击。这是一个人们，特别是教职工谈论时小心翼翼的事，好像他们不想给它带来厄运一样。
The big events of homecoming week, the dance and the game, were on Friday. Thursday afternoon, every student's in the school's bleachers for a pep rally-- cheerleaders, DJ in the front, playing songs that the students dance to, and the staff occasionally feels uncomfortable to.
返校周的盛大活动，舞会和比赛，在周五。周四下午，每个学生都在学校看台上参加动员会——啦啦队、DJ在前面，播放学生们跳舞的歌曲，教职工偶尔也会感到不自在。
[MUSIC - T-PAIN, "BOOTY WURK"]
[音乐 - T-PAIN, "BOOTY WURK"]
(RAPPING) Now let me see that booty work, booty work, booty boo boo booty work. Booty work.
（说唱）现在让我看看那个屁股运动，屁股运动，屁股屁股运动。屁股运动。
This season, Harper's not just undefeated. They've been demolishing other schools-- scores like 46 to 0, 47 to 0. They're good, really good.
本赛季，哈珀不仅不败。他们还横扫了其他学校——比分比如46比0，47比0。他们很棒，真的非常棒。
All right! All right!
好的！好的！
Last year, Harper went to the Chicago Public school championship, a real feat for a school that's so tiny. They were up against a Chicago sports Goliath, Simeon High School, a school known for producing professional athletes.
去年，哈珀进入了芝加哥公立学校锦标赛，这对一所如此小的学校来说是一个真正的壮举。他们面对的是芝加哥体育巨人，西蒙高中（Simeon High School），一所以培养职业运动员而闻名的学校。
The day of the championship, Simeon had four times as many players suited up for the game. Harper's roster is so small just about everybody has to play both offense and defense. Harper lost that game. But they came so close, people are psyched for a second chance.
锦标赛当天，西蒙队穿戴整齐参赛的球员数量是哈珀的四倍。哈珀的名单太小了，几乎每个人都必须同时打进攻和防守。哈珀输掉了那场比赛。但他们如此接近，人们对第二次机会感到兴奋。
And we know the football team tomorrow is going to whoop a little butt on Marshall's!
我们知道橄榄球队明天会把马歇尔高中打得落花流水！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
The team runs in one player at a time, and eventually, they get to a senior, a popular kid named Damoni Ware, who goes by the nickname, "Money."
球队一个接一个地跑入，最后，他们轮到了高三生，一个叫达莫尼·威尔（Damoni Ware）的受欢迎的孩子，他的绰号是“钱”（Money）。
Number 2, Damoni Ware!
2号，达莫尼·威尔！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And Damoni runs out, like everybody else, like a high school kid on a good day. Then just a couple of minutes later, Money's walking out to the front again. This time, it's because he's one of four candidates for Homecoming King.
达莫尼像其他人一样跑出来，就像个好日子里的高中生。然后就在几分钟后，“钱”又向前面走去。这次，是因为他是四名返校节国王候选人之一。
Damoni Ware and Joshua Meyer!
达莫尼·威尔和约书亚·迈耶（Joshua Meyer）！
Josh was walking up that way. I mean, he was a contestant for Homecoming King. And when I was walking up there, they call his name right after mine. And he told me what happened, like, he was nice to me. He said it out loud. He wasn't trying to whisper it or nothing. He just said it in his regular tone of voice. He said, Little James just got shot.
乔什正往那边走。我的意思是，他是返校节国王的选手。当我走在那儿时，他们就在我的名字之后叫了他的名字。他告诉我发生了什么，就像，他对我很友好。他大声说出来了。他没打算耳语或者什么。他只是用正常的语调说的。他说，“小詹姆斯刚刚中枪了。”
Money told us about this later. About how, at the rally, as he stood there with his friend, Josh, Josh was on the phone relaying news about another friend of theirs named James Williams. James had been shot just a few blocks from Harper, meaning probably about the time Money was running under the cheerleaders pompoms, someone was shooting at his friend.
“钱”后来告诉了我们这件事。关于在动员会上，当他和朋友乔什站在一起时，乔什正在电话里转达关于他们另一个叫詹姆斯·威廉姆斯（James Williams）的朋友的消息。詹姆斯就在离哈珀几个街区的地方中枪了，这意味着可能在“钱”跑过啦啦队彩球的时候，有人正朝他的朋友开枪。
He live in this house right here.
他住在这栋房子里。
Money actually lives across the street from James. Standing next to his house, Money can point to James's front door.
“钱”实际上住在詹姆斯街对面。站在他的房子旁，“钱”可以指向詹姆斯的前门。
And this one right there, you see the house with its lights on? And then it's this-- it's this house next to it. And they live in that house right there with the big brown porch. Yeah, he live in that house. His name Little James.
还有那栋，你看那栋灯亮着的房子？然后是那栋——旁边的那栋。他们住在那栋有大棕色门廊的房子里。对，他住在那栋房子里。他叫小詹姆斯。
James Williams, the kid with the big brown porch, the kid who'd been shot during the pep rally, he used to go to Harper. But he hadn't been there this year. Back on the day of the pep rally, minutes after the shooting, the first details coming in were hazy-- just that James had been taken to the hospital, and so far he was still alive.
詹姆斯·威廉姆斯，那个有大棕色门廊的孩子，那个在动员会期间中枪的孩子，他以前上过哈珀。但他今年不在那里。回到动员会那天，枪击发生几分钟后，传来的第一个细节很模糊——只知道詹姆斯被送往医院，到目前为止他还活着。
There was already speculation about who was involved and about possible retaliation by Sixth Ward, the gang that controls the block where James and Money live. Money remembers that, as he left the pep rally, and he went to the last practice on Thursday, before the big game on Friday, he wasn't thinking about the game anymore or homecoming. He was thinking about his friend.
关于谁参与其中以及控制詹姆斯和“钱”居住街区的帮派“第六区”（Sixth Ward）可能进行的报复，已经有了猜测。“钱”记得，当他离开动员会，去参加周四的最后一次练习，在周五的大赛之前，他不再考虑比赛或返校节了。他在想他的朋友。
I didn't know-- I didn't know if he was OK or not. So that had me, like, kind of messing up in practice. Yeah. That threw off my whole day of practice.
我不知道——我不知道他是否没事。所以那让我，就像，练习时有点搞砸了。是的。那搞砸了我一整天的练习。
Like, I was-- I wasn't really running. I was, like, tip toeing. Wasn't really trying to make a tackle, trying to make a play. So I was trying to worry about was he OK.
我没法真正跑动。我就像是踮着脚走路。没真正想去阻截，没真正想去表现。所以我当时在担心他是否安好。
We don't know yet. He was up at the gas station on 67th and Damen, and we just got word that, you know, a former student was shot. So right now, he's in critical condition.
我们还不知道。他在第67街和达门大道（Damen）的加油站，我们刚接到消息，你知道，一名以前的学生被枪击了。所以现在，他在重症监护室。
After school on Thursday, while the football team's practicing, word's spreading about the shooting. Principal Sanders is trying to gather information. And when I find her, she's in the parking lot trying to figure out the school's response.
周四放学后，橄榄球队在练习时，关于枪击的消息传播开来。桑德斯校长正试图收集信息。当我找到她时，她在停车场试图搞清楚学校的应对措施。
And another thing that didn't look good-- three different gangs that came out the door, and they just kind of took off running.
另一件看起来不太好的事——三个不同的帮派从门口出来，他们就那样跑了。
You mean when they just came out of school here?
你是说他们刚从这儿放学的时候？
So they came out, went to the parking lot, and they just took off-- three different groups. For what, we don't know. So that's another indication that something's going on.
所以他们出来，去了停车场，然后他们就跑了——三个不同的团队。为了什么，我们不知道。所以那是另一件表明发生了什么事的迹象。
Sanders' concern is fallout from all this. The homecoming game and the dance are scheduled for the next day. They'll big school events, events where kids from other schools will be, events where security is a challenge. Sanders was worried that James Williams was just the beginning.
桑德斯关心的是这一切带来的后果。返校节比赛和舞会安排在第二天。它们是大型学校活动，外校孩子也会参加，安全是一个挑战。桑德斯担心詹姆斯·威廉姆斯只是个开始。
Definitely-- we have a dance tomorrow. So that's going to have a major effect, especially when they find out exactly who the shooter was. Yeah, that might have a grave impact on whether or not we even have a dance.
当然——我们明天有一个舞会。所以这会产生重大影响，特别是当他们找出到底是谁开的枪时。是的，那可能会对我们是否举办舞会产生严重影响。
Harper staff doesn't just struggle to protect their students from the violence in the neighborhood. They also try to protect what they see as a student's just normal high school experience, things like Homecoming and clubs and prom. Sanders said it was for these reasons that the idea of canceling the dance-- it really bothered her. But she also knew she might have to.
哈珀教职工不仅努力保护他们的学生免受街区暴力侵害。他们还试图保护他们所看到的学生“正常的”高中经历，比如返校节、俱乐部和舞会。桑德斯说正是出于这些原因，取消舞会的想法——这真的让她很烦恼。但她也知道她可能不得不这么做。
Good morning, Harper staff members. At this time, I need all the members for the AAR to report to the Mellon room. Once again, all members for the AAR, please report to the Mellon room at this time.
早上好，哈珀教职工成员。现在，我需要所有AAR成员到梅隆室（Mellon room）报到。再说一遍，所有AAR成员，请现在到梅隆室报到。
And do students know what that is when they hear it?
当学生听到这个时，知道那是什么意思吗？
Not really. They don't really know.
不完全知道。他们不知道。
Friday morning, the day after the shooting, the day of the homecoming game and dance-- this meeting that Sanders is paging people to is an AAR, short for After Action Review, the school's main meeting to figure out how to handle James Williams' shooting. The name AAR actually comes from the military. A couple of years ago, Chicago Public school officials were visiting at Fort Leavenworth in Kansas to research military training tools, tools they might use to prepare people working in the city's roughest schools.
周五早上，枪击案发生后的第二天，返校节比赛和舞会的日子——桑德斯呼叫大家参加的这个会议是AAR，After Action Review（事后回顾）的缩写，学校处理詹姆斯·威廉姆斯枪击案的主要会议。AAR这个名字实际上来自军队。几年前，芝加哥公立学校的官员们访问了堪萨斯州莱文沃斯堡（Fort Leavenworth）研究军事训练工具，他们可能会用来准备在城市最艰难学校工作的人员的工具。
They came across the AAR, the Army's tool for analyzing events, for assessing damage, compiling information, and trying to figure out how to respond. At most schools, this situation-- a former student shot, the threat of more possible shootings-- even schools that have plans for these sorts of crises rarely have to use them. And if they end up in a situation like this, they scramble through it.
他们遇到了AAR，这是军队用来分析事件、评估损失、汇编信息并试图搞清楚如何应对的工具。在大多数学校，这种情况——一名以前的学生中枪，更多潜在枪击的威胁——即使是为这类危机制定了计划的学校也很少使用它们。如果他们陷入这样的境地，他们通常是一团乱麻。
A district administrator told me, think about it. The natural response for a school after a shooting is to go into panic and to grieve, and then to hope that it never happens again. That's normal. And so when the Chicago schools first brought the AAR in from Fort Leavenworth and suggested it to Harper, some people said it felt wrong, like they'd be planning for students to be shot.
一位学区行政人员告诉我，想想看。学校在枪击案后的自然反应是陷入恐慌和悲伤，然后希望再也不要发生。那是正常的。所以当芝加哥学校第一次从莱文沃斯堡引入AAR并向哈珀建议时，有些人说感觉不对劲，好像他们是在策划学生被枪杀一样。
But the staff at Harper knew it would be better to have procedures and a plan to contain the damage. That's the AAR.
但哈珀的员工知道有一个流程和计划来控制损害会更好。那就是AAR。
Marcel, Coach, any word on how James is doing?
马塞尔（Marcel），教练，有詹姆斯状况如何的消息吗？
No.
没有。
OK. Did he have surgery yesterday, or you don't know?
好的。他昨天手术了吗，还是你不知道？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Harper's AAR meeting is held first thing the day after the shooting. One of the first parts of it is just whiteboarding the social and family relationships of the victim to see who could and would be affected and to consider how.
哈珀的AAR会议在枪击案后的第一天举行。其中的一部分仅仅是在白板上写下受害者的社交和家庭关系，看看谁可能会受到影响，以及如何考虑。
OK. So we all know James was shot yesterday right when were getting out, member of Sixth Ward. So I had heard stories about his brother, Jaman, in the neighborhood. Anybody got any word on how he's doing, or--
好的。所以我们都知道詹姆斯昨天放学时中枪了，是第六区的成员。所以我听过关于他弟弟贾曼（Jaman）在街区的传闻。有人收到他如何的消息吗，或者——
The group includes all the deans of the school-- social workers, the football coach, guidance counselors, the psychologist, about two dozen people all together. And the conversation moves pretty fast. They summarize the information they've been able to gather. They list kids with connections to the three gangs involved.
该小组包括学校所有的院长——社会工作者、橄榄球教练、辅导员、心理学家，总共大约两打人。谈话进行得很快。他们总结了他们能够收集到的信息。他们列出了与三个涉及帮派有联系的孩子。
So we already know, number one, that we need to pull all those guys. Can we name them?
所以我们已经知道，第一，我们需要把那些人全部找出来。我们可以叫出他们的名字吗？
[SCHOOL BELL RINGING]
[学校铃声]
Who are they?
他们是谁？
People rattle off names around the room, kids that'll be pulled out of class later.
人们在房间里报出名字，这些孩子稍后会被从课上叫走。
Any freshmen?
有新生吗？
The school just wants to ask them what's going on, what might happen, and to get them out of the building, especially at dismissal time, when things could get dangerous. Money, the football player, James's friend from across the street, they want to ask him what's been happening on the block. They talk about following what kids are saying online and who will do that. A faculty member named Marcel Smith says the students have realized that the school has been monitoring Facebook. They've stopped posting stuff there.
学校只是想问问他们发生了什么，可能发生什么，并让他们离开学校，尤其是在放学时间，那时可能会很危险。“钱”，那个橄榄球运动员，詹姆斯的街对面朋友，他们想问他街区里一直发生什么。他们谈论关注孩子在网上说的话，以及谁会这样做。一位叫马塞尔·史密斯的教职工说，学生们已经意识到学校一直在监控Facebook。他们已经不再在那里发东西了。
And real quick, Principal Sanders, so since they know we on Facebook, everybody's tweeting.
很快，桑德斯校长，因为他们知道我们在Facebook上，每个人都在发推文。
So we ain't got no tweet account with them? Who got a tweet account? So they've done [INAUDIBLE] our game, now?
所以我们没有他们的推特账号？谁有推特账号？所以他们已经搞定[听不清]我们的游戏了，现在？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[不同声音交叉]
Yeah, they off it.
是的，他们不用那个了。
They off of Facebook now?
他们现在不用Facebook了吗？
There's also the issue of James's brother. James left Harper the year before, but his younger brother Jamon still attends. He's not in school that day, but they talk about having someone check on him, and also having someone explain to the kids in each of his classes what happened. They talk about the kids who took off running the night before.
还有詹姆斯弟弟的问题。詹姆斯去年离开了哈珀，但他的弟弟贾蒙（Jamon）还在上学。他今天没来上学，但他们谈论让某人去查看他，并让某人向他每个班的孩子解释发生了什么。他们谈论前一天晚上跑掉的孩子。
--running down the street.
——跑在街上。
Also on the table is the issue of homecoming. Sanders is visibly unsure.
同样在讨论桌上的是返校节的问题。桑德斯明显很拿不准。
If I have not said this, I probably need to say this. So I need as many people at this dance tonight as possible.
如果我没说过这个，我可能需要说一下。我需要今晚舞会上的人尽可能多。
Sanders is married to a Chicago police officer. And so are some other people on staff. Since the previous day, she's been trying to round up off-duty police officers to volunteer as security at the dance. She's also asked Central Office for additional security.
桑德斯的丈夫是一名芝加哥警察。这也是学校里一些其他人的丈夫的职业。自前一天以来，她一直在试图召集休班警察作为舞会的志愿保安。她也向中心办公室申请了额外安保。
But yeah, I need as many people tonight as possible. And when we have dances and things like this, no, I can't pay you. But your presence is definitely needed. Because we need people to watch inside so that nothing happens. As well as-- and I usually have the security, the men, standing outside along with police.
但真的，我今晚需要尽可能多的人。当我们有舞会之类的活动时，不，我不能付钱给你。但你的出席是绝对需要的。因为我们需要人盯着内部，这样什么都不会发生。还有——我通常有保安，这些男士，站在外面和警察一起。
As everyone leaves, Sanders tell someone on staff she's worried about security at the homecoming game itself.
当每个人离开时，桑德斯告诉员工她担心返校节比赛本身的安全。
Because my issue is, if they believe the Breeds did that, half of my football team are Breeds.
因为我的问题是，如果他们认为Breeds帮做了那件事，我一半的橄榄球队员都是Breeds帮的。
Mhm. [INAUDIBLE].
嗯。[听不清]。
So you know what I'm saying? It's not like they pat them down at the games. I don't never see them patting nobody down at the game. You know what I'm saying, I'm, like, so that's hard to-- I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
所以你知道我在说什么吗？比赛的时候又不搜身。我从没见过他们在比赛中搜身。你知道我在说什么，我，就像，所以这很难——我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。
Just so it's clear, what Principal Sanders is saying is that half of her football players have ties to the gangs who are supposedly behind the shooting. And obviously, that's worrisome. Because they might become targets, and they're at the center of every large school event she has planned in the next 24 hours.
为了清楚起见，桑德斯校长说的是，她的一半橄榄球运动员与据称是枪击事件背后的帮派有联系。显然，这很令人担忧。因为他们可能成为目标，而且他们是她计划在未来24小时内举办的每场大型学校活动的核心。
OK. You want to talk to 'em or no? Get over here and talk to Mama.
好的。你想和他们谈谈还是不？过来跟妈妈谈谈。
All day long, Harper's staff implements the plan from the AAR meeting. For Coach Antoine Reed and others, that means spending the day gathering information, pulling students out of class. It's an unusual situation-- sending kids home not because they've done anything wrong, but as a matter of prevention. This student here still hadn't quite figured out that he wasn't in trouble.
整整一天，哈珀的教职工都在执行AAR会议的计划。对于教练安托万·里德（Antoine Reed）和其他人来说，这意味着花一天时间收集信息，把学生从课上叫走。这是一个不寻常的情况——让孩子回家不是因为他们做了错事，而是作为一种预防措施。这个学生甚至还没完全搞清楚他没惹麻烦。
Until I say-- did I ever say you was in trouble? If you are in trouble, who's the first person you think you're going to see? I don't care where you at. I don't care if you on this roof and you get in trouble. The first person you're going to see is me.
直到我——我有没有说过你惹麻烦了？如果你惹麻烦了，你觉得你会见到的第一个人是谁？我不在乎你在哪儿。我不在乎你是否在屋顶上惹麻烦了。你要见到的第一个人是我。
You wasn't in trouble. We understand what's going on and that issue is not resolved yet. He's still in the hospital. Everybody is still angry.
你没惹麻烦。我们了解正在发生什么，那个问题还没解决。他还在医院。大家都很生气。
And we are not taking any chances, you know what I'm saying? So it's not that you in trouble. It's that we're taking precautionary measures. We know how it's going to look today at the end of the day. Let's not be naive. Me and you live around here.
我们不冒险，你明白我在说什么吗？所以不是你惹麻烦了。而是我们正在采取预防措施。我们知道今天结束时会是什么样子。别天真了。我和你就住这附近。
Yeah.
对。
Throughout the day, Principal Sanders shores up the security plan for the game and also for the dance. She's disappointed that more Harper staff don't agree to stay late to act as security.
整整一天，桑德斯校长加强了比赛和舞会的安保计划。她很失望没有更多的哈珀员工同意留下来加班做安保。
You're not going outside at the end of school today?
你今天放学后不出去吗？
No, I'm going to go outside and get in my car and go home.
不，我要出去上车回家。
This is social worker Anita Stewart. Anita tells me she won't be staying late. Just like Coach Reed, she'd spent the day talking to kids about what happened, and she's scared. Anita doesn't want to let Harper down, but with a family and kids of her own, she decided she isn't up for it.
这是社会工作者安妮塔·斯图尔特（Anita Stewart）。安妮塔告诉我她不会留下来。就像里德教练一样，她花了一天时间跟孩子们谈论发生的事，她很害怕。安妮塔不想让哈珀失望，但她自己也有家庭和孩子，她决定她没法留下来。
I'm not going to, you know, go out and stand around. There's too much going on. And I think I got fair warning from the kids to stay out of the neighborhood. And the kids are telling me stay out of the neighborhood. And I'm going to ride with the kids and believe what they're telling me.
我不会，你知道，出去站在那儿。这儿发生的事太多了。我想我从孩子们那里得到了充分的警告，让我远离这个街区。孩子们告诉我要远离这个街区。我要听孩子们的，相信他们告诉我的。
This isn't typical for her. Anita spends a lot of time trying to intervene with kids so they don't end up shooting each other. She's constantly going out into the neighborhood around Harper, after school and on weekends, talking kids down from fighting, going to rival cliques and mediating. Reminding everyone, this is stupid. Stop it.
这对她来说不典型。安妮塔花了很多时间试图介入孩子们的冲突，这样他们就不会互相枪击。她经常在放学后和周末去哈珀周围的社区，劝阻打架的孩子，去敌对小团体那里调解。提醒大家，这很蠢。别再干了。
But today, Anita is struggling. She's sitting in her office, trying to deal with the reality that no matter how much she or anyone does, no matter how much they hope, inevitably, there will be more violence.
但今天，安妮塔在挣扎。她坐在办公室里，试图面对一个现实：无论她或任何人做什么，无论他们抱有多大希望，必然会有更多暴力发生。
The hardest thing is knowing that something is getting ready to happen, and you can't stop it. That hurts. And it's, like, because you don't know where it's going to happen. And you know that the strike is getting ready to come. But you don't know where it's coming. And it hurts.
最难的是知道事情即将发生，但你却无法阻止它。这很痛。而且，就像，因为你不知道它会在哪儿发生。你知道攻击即将到来。但你不知道它从哪儿来。这很痛。
[CRYING]
[哭泣声]
It hurts because they not-- the kids, they're not bad. So you know that something is getting ready to happen, because-- [SNIFFLING] the kids, they tell you, and it's, like, you can't stop it, because you don't know where it's going to happen. And I'm trying to do what I can. [SOBBING]
这很痛，因为他们不是——孩子们，他们不坏。所以你知道事情即将发生，因为——[吸鼻涕]孩子们，他们告诉你，但这就像，你无法阻止，因为你不知道它会在哪儿发生。我正在尽我所能。[啜泣]
Just before dismissal, just like Anita feared, there's news of more shooting. A parent and a student were on their way home, and someone fired shots. Nobody was hit, but it looks like it might have been retaliation.
放学前，就像安妮塔担心的那样，有更多枪击的消息。一名家长和学生在回家的路上，有人开了枪。没人中弹，但这看起来像是报复。
And so the school has to decide what to do next-- cancel the homecoming game, cancel the dance, or risk it. Push back against the violence, and try to preserve a little bit of high school normalcy for the students. Every option they have seems like a bad option. And it's getting late in the day. They have to decide all of this, and they've got to decide soon.
所以学校必须决定下一步做什么——取消返校节比赛，取消舞会，还是冒险一试。反抗暴力，为学生保留一点高中生活的正常感。他们拥有的每一个选择看起来都是个糟糕的选择。天色已晚。他们必须决定这一切，而且他们必须尽快决定。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show. What Principal Sanders and the staff decide to do and how their plan works out, whether they contain the violence-- next week, Alex Kotlowitz, Linda Lutton, and Ben Calhoun will be back. They'll pick up our story where we're leaving it off today, with the second half of our story from Harper High School in Chicago. I hope you join us. I appreciate you in advance for that.
本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）是我们节目的制作人之一。桑德斯校长和教职工决定做什么，他们的计划如何实施，他们是否遏制了暴力——下周，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨、琳达·勒顿和本·卡尔霍恩将回来。他们将从今天结束的地方继续讲述我们在芝加哥哈珀高中的故事。我希望你加入我们。我预先感谢你的收听。
Our program was produced today by our senior producer Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Phia Bennin. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Original scoring for today's program by the Late Bloomer. Music help from Damian Graf and Rob Geddis. Thanks today to [? Coby ?] Williams, Jens Ludwig, Roseanna Ander, [? Joe ?] Jennings, Michelle Harris, [? Rob ?] [INAUDIBLE], Julie Beer.
我们的节目由我们的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩、萨拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）协助。菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）提供制作帮助。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。今天节目的原创配乐由Late Bloomer创作。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graf）和罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。感谢今天的科比·威廉姆斯（Coby Williams）、延斯·路德维希（Jens Ludwig）、罗珊娜·安德（Roseanna Ander）、乔·詹宁斯（Joe Jennings）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、罗布·[听不清]、朱莉·比尔（Julie Beer）。
And special thanks to, of course, Harper principal Leonetta Sanders, head football coach Maris Carroll, social workers Crystal Smith and Anita Stewart, and the rest of the staff, students, and families at Harper High School for being so generous with their time.
当然，特别感谢哈珀校长莱奥内塔·桑德斯，主教练马里斯·卡罗尔（Maris Carroll），社会工作者克里斯托·史密斯和安妮塔·斯图尔特，以及哈珀高中的教职工、学生和家庭，感谢他们如此慷慨地贡献时间。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. I don't know, I keep forgetting to wear my belt to work. I don't know. I don't see what the big deal is. He will not let it go.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。我不知道，我总是忘了系皮带去上班。我不知道。我没觉得那有什么大不了的。他就是不肯罢休。
We are not selling crack. Pull your pants up. Nobody wants to see the crack of your butt, baby.
我们又不是在卖可卡因。把你的裤子提起来。没人想看到你的屁股缝，宝贝。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with Part 2. Be there for more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来播出第2部分。在那里收听更多《美国生活》的故事。